Can I eat Organic popcorn? I'm trying to remember this person's food drivers. I'm sure you're
fine with Organic popcorn. That's just all about moderation. So yes. I want to think everybody should
understand when you're talking about diet and what's driving your cancer and what
you can't. You want to keep in mind the fact that we're testing for what we think is driving
your cancer. Let's say we take you off of dairy. It's the most common thing that we take people
off of. So we use that as an example. So it doesn't mean that other foods don't cause inflammation.
Don't cause it in flammatory process. Just because you have a diagnosis of cancer doesn't mean
you also don't have some sort of hidden autoimmune disease. It doesn't mean you don't also have
also have at the same time food sensitivities and antibodies to different peptides and different foods.
So you got to be aware of that too. And while I'm trying to fight this cancer and I don't want to be
really super restrictive diet for other things too. I know, but let's say let's say you use
the simplest example. Let's say you're you're often dairy for your cancer. That's hard thing to
stay off of. But let's say you have antibodies to gliann and gluten peptides. So gliann is the
protein in gluten. And there are a number of different peptides in gluten portions of that protein
molecule that your body can create antibodies against. And now you have circulated antibodies
against gluten or peptides of gluten. So every time you eat gluten, even though you're trying to do
your best to take care of your cancer, but every time you're causing this inflammatory reaction
and this inflammatory reaction is going to dampen a more specific immune reaction to your cancer.
So you do have to be cognitant of the fact that if you are doing other things that are
is causing a ramped up systemic inflammation in your body, you know, exposing yourself to
GMO foods and, you know, exposing yourself to toxins in your environment that you could stay away
from like boy don't spray in your lawn with chemicals. And doing these things, you are exposing yourself
to to things that is ramping up inflammation from a systemic point of view to your body.
That's going to hinder an immune response against a specific thing like cancer. So you're hindered
your body's ability to kill cancer when you're causing inflammation from some other
source that you could mitigate if you took the steps to do so. So there's, we have patients that
to do a food sensitivity panel for us that are cancer patients because they understand that and they
want to to decrease overall systemic inflammation so their body could concentrate on their immune system,
could concentrate on killing the cancer instead of going after all these things that are
just going to cause problems in their body and it's just causing wrapped up inflammation elsewhere
and doing much worse things, causing damage to different organs. If you have antibodies,
self antibodies to your thyroid, then making somebody made a comment about their thyroid, it's quite
possible that a number of people on this call right now have Hashimoto's also that means you have antibodies
to your thyroid so you should be stayed away from anything that's going to cause a ramped up
inflammation. So getting a Cyrex panel done, which is the best food sensitivity panel because it
measures the different peptides in foods, measures whether the food is cooked, whether food is raw,
that is the most sensitive the best panel to run a Cyrex 10 Cyrex 2 or 3x and 4
measures gluten and gluten cross reactants in a Cyrex 10 measures a whole bunch of other food.
It's valuable panels to know so that your body's not trying to fight the war at multiple fronts
and your immune system can concentrate on trying to kill the cancer instead of being disturbed by
auto antibody responses. Something to think about. So the reason why that
fire that in my mind is because the question about eating popcorn. So yes, you can eat organic popcorn
as long as you don't have any food sensitivity to corn, which is common food sensitivity.
So just because something's not driving you cancer doesn't mean that it's certainly good food. So
we're not saying organic popcorn is bad for you, but if you have antibodies to corn then
it would be bad for you. So you can kind of know those things. You can get some clues about that
without going to test by keeping it a really strong journal that you know everything you eat and
how you feel. You know, within a day after you ate that, you can get some clues to whether
that is a sensitivity or not, but it's hard because typically don't just eat one thing in a given
day so that you're able to test that. You're in a multiple different food sources and you don't
want to lose that you're likely reacting to. And secondly, it's hard to test that from just a
dietary standpoint because you don't always know if you're not wrapped up systemic inflammation.
You don't always get symptoms from it. You're just going to get a decrease to be a response to what
you love to have a healthy body of response to.